you guys were very early obviously to
nanotechnology deep tech whatever you
want to call it now what do you think
are the next area so that next
generation of investors that are coming
up that are sitting there saying I think
that I know something that the
mainstream doesn't where do you think
they're looking right now well I can
tell you where I think smart people are
moving to because again it's like you
know we all read voraciously and we come
up with interesting ideas when we kick
around our partnership but most of the
time it's somebody coming in and us
being like wow like we never thought
about that so over the past few years we
have definitely seen a big thrust of
really smart people at the intersection
between biotech and computer science
sort of computational bio and so whether
that is modeling in silico and then
being able to produce drugs or design
proteins or shorten a drug discovery
cycle the tools that you have
computationally developed mostly for
other IT purposes reaching into the
biotech realm is just absolutely
accelerating that in a really
interesting way and it turns me on
because you have some proprietary
technologies and the markets happened to
be huge because if you can repurpose an
old drug more quickly or get something
through FDA trials more quickly or
better target a potential patient you
know all that is really a creative so
that one's a little obvious and it's
been done over the past few years an
area that I happen to be personally
obsessed with right now is and this sort
of fits with a broad theme across luxe
as the gap between science fiction and
science fact that keeps shrinking is the
gap between simulation and reality and
so when I look across our portfolio
companies often what happens is I start
to see a pattern amongst a bunch of
companies on the con you know if you
sort of extrapolate amongst these
companies there's some interesting
pattern that has emerged and the
interesting pattern when I look at a
company like mater port mater port was
taking 3d scans cameras from Microsoft
Kinect basically assembling them into a
module doing the rapid scan of a
physical space and then using software
on the back end to stitch these things
together so that you could basically
have a video game you know doom like
walkthrough of three-dimensional space
and then extrapolate into a dollhouse
view and it was just like this beautiful
cool thing okay what's the big deal
useful for real estate static images you
know not dynamic
combine that with unity
the gaming engines that are letting you
to render you know in virtually
real-time with ever higher precision and
resolution and so I am seeing across our
companies you look at Zuke's and Ava
that are doing autonomous vehicles or
solid-state lidar to be able to look at
the environment and capture with ever
higher resolution what is actually
happening you look at some of our
companies that are doing this inside of
bio in biotech to be able to image
inside of a cell on the one hand the
ability to capture reality with
technology and tools is getting better
and better than ever before with higher
resolution higher speed so that is sort
of point number one point number two is
the ability to model and simulate what
you have captured now when you have
these two layers the capture and then
the model and simulate then you have a
computational layer between these two
things that are talking to each other
and this turns me on because it's this
basic idea of consciousness and how we
navigate the daily world you have a
memory prediction framework if I see you
and you wearing a Yankee hat or okay so
if I see you and you're always wearing
the Yankee hat or if you know me I'm
always wearing my skull van's when you
see those bands the next time or I see
your Yankee hat the next time and then
you know I didn't see your face if you
look up I'd be like oh that's pump or
you might be like oh that's Josh you're
making a prediction based on a part of
the whole from the memory if suddenly
you were wearing a Boston Red Sox hat I
would have emotional surprise I'd be
like oh I wasn't expecting that
and so I update my priors in like this
Bayesian inference and so a lot of our
computers in the machines from
autonomous vehicles to cell drones to
drones in the sky to defense systems are
doing that they have a model of the
world based on capture they're making
predictions then they're in interacting
with the world based on sensors and then
constantly iterating between these two
things that feedback between the
hardware of capture the software of
simulation and the compute layer between
them is seeing a flood of really
interesting talent and so there will be
people pulled from experiments that went
into augmented reality and virtual
reality which in a form is that it's
capturing what you see in the real world
putting a layer on top of it making
prediction
that will go into all kinds of new
industries that we never anticipated so
that at the moment is something that I'm
really excited about